over the past year a lot of businesses
and families have moved to sky canyon in
the northwest part of the valley yeah
some recent developments are centered
around sky
canyon park drive and sky village road
and reporter kate houston went to the
neighborhood
just off of us 95 to see the changes and
break down what is expected in the year
ahead
throughout 2020 sky canyon marketplace
welcomed one business
after another it's definitely exciting
see a lot of
vacant spaces and we're just excited to
see what's coming in
and all the new restaurants over the
next few months even more businesses
will open in this bustling area
including a barber shop a sushi
restaurant bob's big boy and a locally
owned pet hospital
we're going to be doing low-cost
vaccines
low-cost dental cleanings surgeries
ranging from
just basic spay and neuters to more
complicated orthopedic surgeries
dr gill's animal hospital will open its
doors in april and joins a few other
medical facilities in or near the
marketplace including a 24 7 er from
mountain view hospital
which is under construction the more
businesses that come
i'm pretty sure it's going to attract
more people and
especially with the essential businesses
in addition to new businesses sky canyon
is also adding new homes
here you can see crews hard at work
building up the next residential area
there are currently 13 different sky
canyon communities selling homes
out of the 2300 available 1900 have
already been sold to families like robin
hargett and her husband
we were looking for a change and we got
a hold of our realtor and he told us
this was the new
nice booming area a great family
community
with lots of great parks and still a lot
of stores around us
and all my favorites kate houston 8 news
now
sky canyon is also in the process of
developing two new parks they will
include hoops courts fields children
play areas and
one will have a dog park as well which
is always welcome
ted